and then we have these women that are
living in absolute delusion an example
of that is I saw a morbidly obese woman
talking about
incels imagine imagine being morbidly
obese and having the audacity the
audacity to on
incels I mean at least the incel you
know most incels or whatever are just
kind of nerdy scrawny guys at least
they're not
be anyways let's pull it up can you
explain what an incel is so an incel is
just like someone who is involuntarily
cibit that loser sitting on Reddit for
23 hours a day um with cheetah dust and
empty Mountain Dew cans all around them
and it just has a real stank smell that
is involved with these people because
I'm just going to PID you an image and
like the F door is a little crusty and
the the beard the the neck beard is
strong but the facial hair is weak and
there's a B Spot in the back and you can
just and you can just see the Fedora
just hanging on for dear life and he's
sitting there mut muttering under his
breath about how like Jessica Alba's
ugly right you know that's what you're
talking
about so this woman has the audacity to
talk about incels really an incel
is way better than that that is
disgusting Jesus like I I'd say get on
the treadmill but I don't even think she
can get on it I don't even think she
could like I would say maybe start like
walking oh this is crazy but that's how
delusional she is that's how crazy that
is and the comment section picked this
up immediately they said I don't think
she's in the position to talk about
somebody's
Health
yes um she thinks she's on the same
level as the other girl I don't know
what she thinks but I don't know how you
could call them losers I mean there's
nothing nothing more loser likee than
being in your prime years and being
morbidly obese this is the same woman
that would say calling her fat is a hate
crime I just don't understand how these
these chicks have the audacity it's like
the audacity you are morbidly
obese I you got to get off the podcast
it's time to start start walking all
right the worst part with these
Housewives is a guys do you know how
many Housewives and how many just okay
over over the last couple of years I
have interviewed thousands of people
these are the conclusions that I come to
from interviewing thousands of people
women leave their husbands for the
stupidest and dumbest reasons I have
ever heard in my life very few times
have I heard actually legit reasons for
divorce and I thought about the most
common reason that I get for leaving the
father of your children or their husband
and it is that these women outgrew him
the amount of women that I have met that
casually destroyed their entire families
because they outgrew their husbands is
genuinely depressing I tweeted yesterday
and what you typically get from the
modern mothers that are coping and can't
accept the fact that they actually made
the wrong most selfish decision that
they have ever made in their life oh let
me just put my kid at every statistical
disadvantage oh let me only see both of
my parents half the time in the month oh
let me make my kid more likely to run
away from home more likely to drop out
of school and more likely to be abused
because of my feelings of outgrowing him
Miss doso says divorce does not break a
family it only transforms it and we see
the women coping no the data does not
support your thesis it does not it
significantly impacts the children and
the Children of Divorce will back this
up men women can't you just learn to get
along why do we have to break up the
family and hurt the innocent people the
kids the kids and it's so it's so funny
women are so self-centered that they
they use every single cat to make their
selfish decision not sound like a
selfish decision paladin says men can
change like women can too the issue is
that hous making means stability and
growth isn't good or bad but it
certainly isn't stable it is volatile by
default it would make a lot of sense
that the hormonal gender is more
volatile and gross the default is for
men to stabilize the family so yeah you
get what you asked for and it isn't
enough by the way change isn't growth
and many think it is another topic
though yeah I mean men can change too
but they're not destroying their
families by and large you know what's
funny when women win the lottery they
tend to divorce their husbands when men
win the lottery they tend to stay Emily
Webb says outgrew means they realize
they needed better or different there's
nothing wrong with that you see how
diluted this is there's nothing wrong
okay what is neat really guys I honestly
think I could get along with anybody if
you give me enough time I really do so
what is what is you needed different
really it was a want getting the husband
or the wife that you want is a luxury
okay and sometimes you you make your bed
and you you maybe didn't pick the
husband that you wanted or whatever and
women of the past used to just lie in it
and just deal with it and life wasn't
all about relation like the women of the
past just dealt with their choices and
made the best of it because they cared
more about their family their community
and their children but the women of
today do not care about their children
they care more about their feelings and
what they want and what they need really
before the 1900s the collective was the
most important the family was the most
important but now we are pedal and told
these lies that it's all about me and my
feelings and what I want and that's not
what life should be about Sandy says I
think it's important to understand the
destruction occurs a lot sooner than the
divorce papers and it is not always in
the couple's control this seems to be a
crucial point that escapes
many okay let me get this straight
filing for
divorce is not in the couple's control
learning to get along with
somebody is not in your control
really all right so now we have another
simp simp simp simp simp simp simp simp
simp simp simp simp here's I could be
like Oprah there's a simp there's a simp
there's another simp simp simp
simp because these men do not help us
they are just liars because they want to
look good to everybody and they want to
Pander to women and get late what about
the masses what about the masses of men
who cheated on their wives because their
wives boobs started sagging and the
younger women at their jobs flirted with
them I have never heard that story in my
life I have never heard a story of a guy
that said oh my wife's boob started
sagging so let me just but do you know
what story I've heard a million times
men that have been in sexless marriages
for years and then cheat and we never
talk about it it's always oh he cheated
he's evil but we never talk about why he
cheated the nagging woman or the nagging
wife that demasculate her husband for
years for years you know women of the
past used to work through cheating and
you could see it in the culture I mean
look at the song Jolene by Dolly Parton
she was begging the side chick not to
take her husband she's saying please
please I love this man I love it but now
oh it's the victim he's evil I'm amazing
and awesome and special I'm done I'm
done with this you I can't
pander I can't lie all of these simps
are just liars and I can't stand it and
I'm not going to read this stuff anymore
and not call it out you're a s sir s i m
p simp that should be the no new song
you know how they got like the
promiscuous or like the what was that
Fergie song it's like where they spell
it out someone should make a song where
it's like you're a s you're a you're s m
p simp thank you honestly Pearl Jessica
Jones
honestly Pearl God didn't bother
creating women to just cook and clean
for men and if women are so useless
compared to men why not just give men
the ability to procreate without us in
general since the majority of life on
Earth requires a male and a female to
create life well Jessica they're
starting to you know if I say that
children are less competent than adults
is that an insult women are less
competent by and large than men I
occasionally you have a prodigy kid that
just is very good and you're like wow
what a what a child but it's still a
child the other thing she
says why not just give men the ability
to procreate without us they're working
on it I mean guys all we had to do all
we had to do was provide some value in
the world and the best way that women
when we got freedom found a provide
value was only fans and sex work it's
like
I honestly think if men had kids by
themselves the kids would turn out
better than what we have now I I know I
know we have all these mental health
issues we have all of these kids that
are growing up to be criminals rude
disrespectful it's because all these
moms just outgrow their husbands and
think huh let me just let me just be by
myself oh it's going to be amazing and
let me Rob let me Rob the guy through
child support and alimony for a life
time amazing let me just have my free
ride we have 50 years of women that just
love having a free ride I'm tired of it
I'm tired of the laziness you don't have
to be a lazy bimbo ladies you really
don't